is there any games you like that AR RPGs
lately yeah well I do believe that one
of these games that's sweeping the world
is this one where you match fruits
together right oh my gosh and I played
it for like three hours and set the
highest score out of everybody that we
know and so that what's the problem why
can't you do well it's so easy you it
pisses me off how close you were to
Greatness and you stopped yeah I don't
need greatness I already it's defined
with the high score was you could have
got the Fable double
SU explain what this is so basically
it's a child's game you stack you stack
up different fruits you match two
strawberries you get a grape two grapes
me a meon or whatever yeah and all these
bozos are trying their best to beat it I
needed that game for like an hour it's
really funny watching these like fully
grown ass adults just like playing this
children's game it for Ser but for me
actually to answer your question
truthfully every genre on the table I
get labeled a lot as a retro gamer
because I like y retro
this is it this is actually it but uh I
actually prefer you know a lot of the
modern games as well so it's like
anything in all game like well not that
one but yeah it's like uh I just love
video games and it's it's what are some
of the modern games then uh what's come
out recently that's been pretty good is
things like lies of P or you know
Spider-Man 2 or what are the big games
that have come out that if cuz this
year's been pretty bleak yeah has it
well balis Gate 3 play Legend of Zelda I
thought Legend of Zelda breath of the
boring uh wild too that that is that is
an LTE that's such an L wait what it's
all right I I I I'm fine with dying on
that I don't [__] with the whole
building on the new one I I don't like
it the building is the best part I don't
like that and it's like it's like
Minecraft I hate that I hate that if I
want to play Minecraft play Minecraft no
I feel like if you I feel like we talked
about this last time too I feel you say
breath of the boring I feel like if you
replace link with any other character
it's it's going to be the same great
game that it already is but this not a
Zelda game it's just oh no I don't
include it as a Zelda game well there
you go see that's if we're going to not
but it's still a great game it is a
great I mean like yeah but I think it's
like it's it's kind of just cashing in
on putting you know there's there's
there's breath of the wild and tears of
the kingdom and then there's every other
Zelda game in my mind that's that's
exactly how I feel so sad for me but
yeah I think like balers Gate 3 was
great but these are RPGs though yeah RPG
more RPG I mean like I'm just trying to
think Elden ring was last year yeah
Elden ring was last year I feel like
this year has been kind
of I I feel like I don't know hey Super
Mario RPG remakes coming out though I
will be playing that on Sunday that's
coming out comes this comes out this
weekend this weekend oh wow it's be hope
it's good it almost feels like there
there's like my my backlog of every time
I complete a game I'm it seems like
every time I'm just in the cust of
completing a game there's a new like
[__] Mass massive game that comes out
at least this year 3 remake they make
all the games to do is make an agreement
to time out their games to get
G boy I feel like the the tener of this
episode has been I have really horrible
takes on everything no is that a normal
trash taste thing me you fit right in
they've heard all of our opinions so we
just want to you know ask about yours
some new fresh bad tastes we need some
new material good games yeah no we want
we want the bad takes but good takes a
boring Peak takes some boring yeah it's
pretty wild though to to think about y
harambe take is definitely my favorite
though that's not even a take real a
tast yeah but it's a funny believe that
happened I'm very upset natural causes
natural causes died of a heart attack
from that poor child who fell in I
imagined like in my mind harambe was
wearing like some bathrobe and it was
cinched up and it
was and it just just died it's like damn
I can't believe this child fell in peace
rest in peace I guess you are right I
don't know nothing's been out man yeah
this year has been pretty boring for
video games I think cuz I don't care
about Spider-Man I don't care about I
play Spider-Man it's good it's good yeah
but I heard it was like just the first
game DLC I mean sure I mean I played it
for the story and that was pretty much
it um sometimes more you final like
that's crazy you count Final Fantasy 16
is a big release but we're not counting
RPGs right like we're not counting
that's the thing this year and early
next year is all RPG y this is like the
year of
RPGs we are shoters are kind of out
nowar Wars Jedi Survivor I
that street street fighter six oh I that
would probably be oh that was a big Rel
that was probably my favorite game this
year oh yeah yeah that looks insane as a
consumer I like to watch it I like to
follow it yeah no no I mean I I mean
like we got to play it first we played
it but I've not like gotten into it cuz
it's it's a fighting game fighting game
fighting games are like like obviously
it's his own genre but I feel like out
of every genre it's one of the hardest
genres to get into but I think Street
Fighter 6 did make an effort to to like
like the easy
controls yeah but yeah games are out
this year it's kind of a it's a great
time to be a stream [__] watermelon
game man yeah I'm not too concerned with
that I already beat it yeah easy and uh
I wish I could beat it I will say like
one thing that I'm I'm not proud of much
obviously I I don't
I don't have a lot of things that I hang
my hat on but I am glad that all these
years starting with like the Commodore
and the Atari and the Nintendo uh when
we were at twitch Rivals we had to play
that party anim oh that was so fun yeah
and I still feel in these these ancient
hands if you give me a controller or a
game I can adapt quickly enough you're
making it sound like you're like an old
Grand Master or something I'm telling
you man it's a young man's game like his
third eye opens it does we uh we
competed in a ultimate twitch Rivals it
was really fun to be fair uh and uh we
had to do a series of different like
casual things like physical and game and
party animals was one of them and all of
us were pretty bad except for we never
played yeah we had a guy called five up
with us who was pretty good and kind of
helped us uh and we ended up winning
first place yeah we got first place in
that in that event and then we we then
when the physical stuff I that's when
age the mind was willing but the body
was unable but the crazy thing is like I
I do feel getting to play games and just
still having that because like Esports
players whatever they're like 22 and
they're retired they're like I can't
play rocket League anymore 22 is like
old ancient yeah you need to be you need
to come up when you're like 16 17 this
is the oldest uh this League of Legends
competition is the oldest it's ever been
the players so what's the average age 19
I think it's like 25
now
12 that's a fortnite competition I me
League of Legends has G to a point now
where um I'm not sure how many new
players it's getting it's a lot of the
older players cuz the old players just
keep coming back every time and uh we
had we had one of we had one person in
the league uh Worlds Final this year
that was like a dad he was like in his
30s he was getting his ass clapped by
like
everyone there we go according to a
survey conducted by ESPN in 2018 the
average age of professional League of
Legends Esports players is 21.2 years
old but now in this this world is a yeah
it's a 24 to 25 yeah it's generally
older which is kind of cool I I like
that it's it's getting to that point now
where people have been in the Esports
for so long and they're aging still
keeping up with kids who are 19 you got
a chance Pete you got a chance well to
me it's like I just are you are you into
competitive games not particularly but I
I am comp but do you have a competitive
comp you have a competitive he get
[__] are you kidding me this man's
competitive well I mean it's like it
sucks when you're so good at a lot of
the games that I play no I'm kidding but
are are are you one of those
[__] who opens up like a you
know like a game of OverWatch he bides
his time wait for game if let's just try
our best guys it's okay it's okay guys
or do you have like a toxic gamer side
to I don't have a toxic gamer well he's
very gracious and the moment he knows
that he can kick your ass he'll go full
toxic F you're so bad why are you so bad
at the game I just can't understand how
bad you are it makes no sense that you
play so long no I think like for me in
when you have a group of friends who
play video games back in the day there's
always one of you who are going to be
fundamentally better than the rest of
the group sure and it's not fun to Lord
that over each other and try to do like
let's play Golden Eye where I always win
first place or we're going to play Halo
where I'm always on the Stacked team
right so for me that's always been kind
of the role that I've been in but when
you play other groups who are
competitive you quickly learn that
you're at the midlevel of like gaming so
I feel like I've never really purposely
tried to be in a I was in like a Team
Fortress classic clan when I was 15 like
you know hell yeah the old game that was
like number one oh no no we were it was
so different back then you had to like
organize when to fight each other and
you had to get on Roger Wilco or
ventrillo which were old TeamSpeak um oh
my God team speak feels ancient too
exist there was no built-in clients and
so you had to do things kind of very
differently CU there was nothing in the
game itself to set it up but other than
that being competitive I just I just
really like the challenge of applying
all the games I've played I can see
patterns relatively quickly and I I find
that to be very exciting I'm such a nerd
this is so bad it's like could forand
could recognize patents quickly but
thought that harambe died of I feel like
I put my points you are you just like
gaming Rainman right now I'm like it's
like yeah just going to controlling you
like it's really I can't stop this
power no but what it is is it's it's
something that I'm so thankful it's so
cool to have grown up with them all oh
totally like to not have to come into
like my first console was a 360 I can't
imagine not started You' literally been
there since the beginning that's that's
dope as hell it's pretty awesome like
trade that for much what do you think of
the modern gaming industry then I think
it's it's really great I think that what
I like the most is the how Indies have
come up because I think Indie developers
are basically people my age who really
miss a lot of the games that we used to
play the old style of games and so
they're saying well we can still
innovate on the limitations that the old
consoles had and make these cool games
and then you get some really cool AAA
titles here and there that are still fun
to kind of you know put some time into
but yeah it's a good place I think it's
like the thing about Alea games is that
it just feels like it's you know it's
kind of like watching a Blockbuster
movie you don't get as much personality
not as much
like individual expression but you know
it's it's like nice to like get a you
kind of like feel like you're like
getting the popcorn out and just
watching a Blockbuster movie in a
theater lately the meme is that all
indie games are Rog likes yeah it is a
big Trend right there's a huge portion
of them sidescroller Rog likes just any
Rog likes card deck card Builder Ro
likes or whatever but you know I mean
it's just cuz obviously that given the
tools there's only like you know it's a
little harder to develop certain things
yeah I love R I'm not complaining I like
I like I feel like those are it's really
hard to create something narratively
strong that has a specific Vision And
Rog likes allow a lot of player and
Creator expression but I still really
like like it's all RPGs but like chain
deos and sea of stars which are made by
like one guy or a team of two or three
that's pretty impressive that there's
like one single game there inscription I
liked lot
great well yeah that part one's amazing
part two is pretty good three's three is
pretty bad but P one is amazing